MARIA:  AND FIRST THIS MORNING,
MORE CONFUSION AND ARROGANCE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> I’VE SEEN MORE --
[LAUGHTER]
--
>> MORE OF DR. FAUCI THAN I HAVE
OF MY WIFE.
WE KID EACH OTHER.
LOOK, WHO’S PRESIDENT?
FAUCI.
ALL KIDDING ASIDE, I SINCERELY
MEAN IT.
MARIA:  YES, WHO IS PRESIDENT,
JOE BIDEN JOKING THIS WEEK THAT
DR. ANTHONY FAUCI IS THE REAL
PRESIDENT AS THE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF’S POLL NUMBERS PLUMMET TO
NEW LOWS AND RED STATES LIKE
FLORIDA AND TEXAS SHOW THE
LOWEST NUMBER OF COVID
INFECTIONS AND SOME OF THE
HIGHEST INVESTMENT DOLLARS
ANYWHERE.
JOINING ME RIGHTS NOW IS
GOVERNOR OF THE GREAT STATE OF
TEXAS, GREG ABBOTT IS HERE.
GOVERNOR, THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
BEING HERE.
CONGRATS TO YOU ON A LOT OF GOOD
NEWS.
I WANT TO GET TO YOUR
INVESTMENTS FROM TESLA AND
SAMSUNG IN A MOMENT BUT FIRST
TELL US ABOUT THE OMICRON
VARIANT, WHAT HAS IT MEANT FOR
TEXAS, WHERE ARE YOU ON THE
COVID INFECTIONS?
>> SO FOR ONE, BECAUSE -- YOU
TALKED ABOUT HOW WE HAVE A LOW
RATE OF INFECTIONS COMPARED TO
SO MANY OTHER STATES AND ONE
REASON THAT WE’VE BEEN ABLE TO
ACHIEVE THAT IS BECAUSE WE’VE
BEEN OPEN, 100%.
THERE ARE NO VACCINE MANDATES OR
MASK MANDATES AND SO IT SHOWS
THAT WE CAN REMAIN OPEN AND HELP
LIVELIHOODS WHILE ALSO MAKING
SURE THAT WE DO A GOOD JOB OF
PROTECTING LIVES.
AS IT CONCERNS THE NEW VARIANT,
WE’RE BEING VERY AGGRESSIVE IN
TRYING TO ADDRESS IT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE HEALTH
SERVICES IS WORKING WITH LOCAL
HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS ACROSS THE
STATE TO BE ABLE TO TEST SAMPLES
OF COVID POSITIVE CASES TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT THEY DO
CONTAIN THE NEW VARIANT.
WE’RE WORKING TO MAKE SURE THAT
VACCINES ARE AVAILABLE TO
ANYBODY WHO WANTS A VACCINE AND
ALSO WORKING TO MAKE SURE WE
MAKE IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO GET
A TEST SO THEY CAN DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT THEY MAY HAVE THE
NEW VARIANT OR JUST HAVE THE
DELTA VARIANT, WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE BUT ALSO WE IN
ANTICIPATION OF A POTENTIAL
INCREASE IN HOSPITALIZATIONS,
WE’RE WORKING TO SURGE MORE
NURSING AND MEDICAL PERSONNEL TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR HOSPITALS
WILL BE ABLE TO DEAL WITH IT.
MARIA:  WELL, IT’S PRETTY
EXTRAORDINARY WHEN YOU LOOK AT
WHAT’S GOING ON IN EUROPE RIGHT
NOW, GOVERNOR.
YOU’VE GOT LOCKDOWNS IN AUSTRIA,
GERMANY LOCKING DOWN
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
BECAUSE THE WHITE HOUSE HAS NOT
RULED OUT A VACCINE MANDATE FOR
DOMESTIC TRAVELERS.
WE’RE WAITING TO SEE WHERE THIS
OMICRON STORY GOES NEXT.
>> WELL, I CAN TELL YOU IN
TEXAS WE ARE RULING OUT VACCINE
MANDATES.
WE’RE RULING OUT LOCKDOWNS.
THERE’S NO NEED FOR THINGS LIKE
THAT.
TEXANS KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO IN ORDER TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES AND THEY DON’T NEED
GOVERNMENT TELLING THEM WHAT TO
DO.
I THINK THE SAME THING SHOULD
APPLY FOR THE WHITE HOUSE.
MARIA:  SO TEXAS IS OPEN AND
THRIVING AND YOU HAVE HAD
MULTIPLE NUMBER OF VICTORIES
THIS WEEK ALONE.
A FEDERAL JUDGE BLOCKING JOE
BIDEN FROM ENFORCING THE TWO
MANDATES REQUIRING MILLIONS OF
WORKERS TO GET VACCINATED.
YOUR EXECUTIVE ORDER BANNING
MASK MANDATES BY GOVERNMENT
ENTITIES BECOMES LAW.
TELL ME ABOUT THE ECONOMIC STORY
IN TEXAS.
I KNOW THAT TESLA ANNOUNCED IT’S
OFFICIALLY MOVING ITS
HEADQUARTERS FROM SILICON VALLEY
TO AUSTIN.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN FOR TEXAS
AND THEN THERE’S SAMSUNG,
COMMITTING TO A $17 BILLION
SEMICONDUCTOR FACTORY IN TAYLOR,
TEXAS.
THIS IS GOING TO BE REAL
IMPACTFUL, NOT JUST FOR TEXAS,
BUT FOR THE COUNTRY AS WE BATTLE
THIS SHORTAGE OF SEMICONDUCTOR
CHIPS.
>> WELL, IT’S HUGE.
I’LL ADDRESS BOTH ISSUES THAT
YOU RAISE AND THAT IS, FIRST,
TEXAS HAS BEEN VERY AGGRESSIVE
ABOUT LEGALLY CHALLENGING ALL OF
THESE MANDATES THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT IN PLACE
CONCERNING COVID.
AND WHETHER IT BE VACCINE
MANDATES OR MASK MANDATES,
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE.
AND WE’VE BEEN WINNING THEM ALL
IN THE COURTS AND RIGHT NOW IN
TEXAS THERE ARE NO FEDERAL
MANDATES THAT APPLY.
THE ONLY MANDATE THAT APPLIES IS
MY EXECUTIVE ORDER SAYING THAT
NOBODY IN THE STATE OF TECHS AS
CAN BE MANDATED TO TAKE A
VACCINE SHOT.
OBVIOUSLY THEY’RE AVAILABLE FOR
ANYBODY WHO WANTS IT.
BUT THERE CAN BE NO MANDATES
INFRINGING UPON INDIVIDUAL
LIBERTY.
THAT IS IN PART WHY I THINK
THERE ARE SO MANY BUSINESSES
THAT ARE MOVING IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS AND MARIA, OVER JUST THE
FIRST 11 MONTHS OF THIS YEAR
THERE HAVE BEEN 70 BUSINESSES
AND CORPORATIONS THAT HAVE
RELOCATED THEIR HEADQUARTERS TO
THE STATE OF TEXAS.
IF YOU LOOK ON AVERAGE, THAT
MEANS THERE’S A NEW HEADQUARTERS
IN TEXAS EVERY FIVE DAYS.
ONE OF THOSE AS YOU MENTIONED IS
TESLA THAT FIRST ANNOUNCED THEIR
GIGA FACTORY IN THE STATE AND
ANNOUNCED THEIR HEAD QUARTER
MOVE.
SAMSUNG, $17 BILLION INVESTMENT
IN TAYLOR, TECHS TEXAS, JUST OUT
OF AUSTIN WHERE THEY WILL BUILD
ADDITIONAL SEMICONDUCTORS.
TEXAS INSTRUMENTS ANNOUNCED A
$30 BILLION INVESTMENT FOR
SEMICONDUCTORS.
THOSE SEMICONDUCTORS WILL HELP
IN THE SUPPLY CHIN PROCESS --
CHAIN PROCESS.
THE STATE OF TEXAS ECONOMY IS
GROWING AND THRIVING AND THERE
ARE BUSINESS THAT’S ARE MOVING
HERE THAT ARE GROWING HERE
BECAUSE TEXAS IS THE LAND OF
ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY AND
INNOVATION.
MARIA:  WELL, THIS IS A HUGE
STORY AND THIS IS GOING TO HAVE
IMPACT THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
WE KNOW RIGHT NOW THE DOMINANCE
OF TAIWAN ON SEMICONDUCTORS.
ONE OTHER REASON THAT CHINA
WANTS TO GO IN, ACQUIRE TAIWAN,
SO THEY CAN BE IN CHARGE OF ALL
SEMICONDUCTORS.
THIS IS GOING TO ALLEVIATE THE
SEMICONDUCTOR PROBLEM AND
SHORTAGE THAT AMERICA IS FACING.
SO THAT’S JUST GREAT NEWS FOR
TEXAS.
DO YOU EXPECT MORE?
WHAT ARE YOU EXPECTING IN TERMS
OF MORE INVESTMENT COMING DOWN
THE ROAD?
ANY VISION OR RUNWAY FOR US?
>> SURE.
WE GOT ACTUALLY A LOT OF
POSITIVE PROJECTS THAT ARE
COMING OUR WAY BUT LISTEN, YOU
TOUCHED UPON SOMETHING THAT IS
VERY IMPORTANT AND THAT IS A
LESSON THAT AMERICANS HAVE
LEARNED AND BY GOD THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION SHOULD LEARN THIS
ALSO AND THAT IS THE COUNTRY
MADE A MISTAKE OVER THE PAST ONE
OR TWO DECADES TO FARM OUT
MANUFACTURING OF ALL THESE
ESSENTIAL SUPPLIES, WHETHER IT
BE NOW SEMICONDUCTORS OR COULD
BE HEALTHCARE SUPPLIES THAT WE
NEEDED DURING THE TIME OF COVID,
WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE.
WE NEED TO NOT DEPEND UPON CHINA
OR OTHER COUNTRIES FOR OUR
ESSENTIAL NEEDS, FOR THINGS LIKE
SEMICONDUCTORS AND THAT IS
EXACTLY WHY TEXAS ACTUALLY IS
LEADING THE WAY, BECOMING THE
HOME FOR SEMICONDUCTORS THAT GO
INTO EVERYTHING THAT PEOPLE USE.
IT’S NOT JUST YOUR iPHONE OR
YOUR LAPTOP OR WHATEVER THE CASE
MAY BE.
IT’S ALSO IN ALL OF THESE
VEHICLES WHERE YOU HAVE
MANUFACTURING GOING ON.
IN FACT, JUST THIS LAST WEEK WE
ANNOUNCED THE ROLLOUT OF THE NEW
TOYOTA TUNDRA.
THEY USE SEMICONDUCTOR CHIPS IN
THEIR TRUCKS.
TEXAS WILL BE THE HOME OF
SEMICONDUCTOR MANUFACTURING
GOING FORWARD.
MARIA:  ALL THE MORE IMPRESSIVE,
GIVEN WHAT YOU ARE FACING IN
TERMS OF THE CHALLENGE AT THE
BORDER.
SO BECAUSE OF THE OMICRON
VARIANT, JOE BIDEN CAME OUT THIS
WEEK AND PUT NEW MASK
RESTRICTIONSES, MASK MANDATES
RATHER IN PLACE UNTIL MARCH OF
2022.
AND HE WAS ASKED ABOUT COVID
TESTING, GIVEN THE FACT THAT NOW
TRAVELERS COMING INTO THE UNITED
STATES ARE REQUIRED TO TEST FOR
COVID WITHIN 24 HOURS.
HERE’S DR. FAUCI ANSWERING THE
QUESTION FROM FOX NEWS STAR,
PETER DOOCY, ABOUT TESTING COVID
AT THE BORDER.
WATCH THIS.
>> ANYBODY AND EVERYBODY WHO IS
COMING INTO THE COUNTRY NEEDS TO
GET A TEST WITHIN 24 HOURS OF
GETTING ON THE PLANE TO COME
HERE.
>> WHAT ABOUT PEOPLE WHO DON’T
TAKE A PLANE AND JUST THESE
BORDER CROSSERS COMING IN IN
HUGE NUMBERS.
>> THAT’S A DIFFERENT ISSUE.
FOR EXAMPLE, WHEN YOU TALK -- WE
STILL HAVE TITLE 42 WITH REGARD
TO PROTECTION AT THE BORDER, SO
THERE ARE PROTECTIONS AT THE
BORDER THAT YOU DON’T HAVE THE
CAPABILITY AS YOU KNOW OF
SOMEBODY GETTING ON A PLANE,
GETTING CHECKED, LOOKING AT A
PASSPORT.
WE DON’T HAVE THAT THERE.
MARIA:  GOVERNOR, SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT FOR US.
WHO IS NOT GETTING TESTED AT THE
BORDER AND ALSO WE DO HAVE
BREAKING NEWS THIS MORNING, WE
HAVE THE LATEST UNOFFICIAL
BORDER NUMBERS FROM OUR BORDER
SOURCES FOR THE MONTH OF
NOVEMBER AND IT IS GETTING
WORSE.
WE HAD 168,000 APPREHENSIONS FOR
THE MONTH AND 52,429 GOT-AWAYS,
IN OTHER WORDS, THOSE PEOPLE
CAME INTO THE COUNTRY, SEEN ON
SURVEILLANCE CAMERAS, THEY GOT
AWAY.
WE ARE LOOKING AT 600,000
GOT-AWAYS THIS FISCAL YEAR, UP
40%.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON TESTING FOR
COVID AND ALL OF THIS IMPACT OF
THE WIDE OPEN BORDER IN TEXAS.
>> MARIA, I’M UNAWARE WHETHER
OR NOT DR. FAUCI HAS EVER
ACTUALLY BEEN TO THE BORDER.
CERTAINLY DURING THE TIME OF
COVID, I DON’T THINK HE HAS ANY
PERSONAL FIRSTHAND KNOWLEDGE
WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE ARE BEING
TESTED COMING ACROSS THE BORDER.
I, HOWEVER, AM ON THE BORDER
EITHER EVERY WEEK OR EVERY OTHER
WEEK AND I’VE BEEN DEALING WITH
AND TALKING TO BORDER PATROL AS
WELL AS THE TEXAS NATIONAL GUARD
AND THE TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY WHO ARE
APPREHENDING THESE PEOPLE COMING
ACROSS THE BORDER AND WHAT I CAN
TELL YOU FOR A FACT IS MOST OF
THE PEOPLE COMING ACROSS THE
BORDER, IF NOT ALL OF THEM, ARE
NOT BEING TESTED.
THE POINT IS THIS.
THE PRESIDENT AND THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, THEY HAVE TWO
STANDARDS.
IF YOU’RE GOING TO PAY MONEY TO
COME INTO THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA LAWFULLY, YOU HAVE TO BE
TESTED.
HOWEVER, IF YOU COME INTO THE
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY, YOU DON’T
HAVE TO BE TESTED.
AS YOU KNOW, THE NUMBERS, THERE
HAVE BEEN MORE THAN A MILLION
PEOPLE WHO HAVE COME ACROSS THE
BORDER ILLEGALLY THAT WE KNOW OF
THIS YEAR.
MOST OF WHOM HAVE NOT BEEN
TESTED.
SO THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ACTUALLY HAS NO ADEQUATE
INFORMATION TO DETERMINE THE
EXTENT TO WHICH PEOPLE ARE
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER BY THE
MILLIONS TO KNOW WHETHER OR NOT
THEY ARE BRINGING COVID OR THE
OMICRON VARIANT, WHATEVER THE
CASE MAY BE, INTO THE UNITED
STATES OF AMERICA.
THAT IS COMPLETELY IRRESPONSIBLE
AND EXTREMELY DANGEROUS.
YOU TALKED ABOUT --
MARIA:  ABSOLUTELY.
>> THE GOT-AWAYS, THE REASON WE
HAVE GOT-AWAYS, IT’S BECAUSE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS TIED
THE HANDS OF BORDER PATROL AND
I.C.E.
THEY HAVE INSUFFICIENT NUMBERS
TO SECURE THE BORDER.
THESE WHY TEXAS HAS 10,000
NATIONAL GUARD AND DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY OFFICERS ON THE
BORDER, THAT’S WHY WE’RE
ERECTING BARRIERS ON THE BORDER,
IT’S WHY TEXAS IS BUILDING ITS
OWN BORDER WALL.
MARIA:  EXACTLY.
ONE OF MY SOURCES TOLD ME ABOUT
THE LAWLESSNESS HAPPENING IN
HOUSTON.
HE TOLD ME THERE WERE 400,000
NEW PEOPLE IN HOUSTON RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE THERE ARE GET-AWAY CARS
PICKING THEM UP FROM THE BORDER,
DRIVING THEM TO HOUSTON.
I WAS TOLD ONE OF THE BIGGEST
BUSINESSES IN HOUSTON RIGHT NOW
IS PRODUCING FAKE DOCUMENTS.
THAT THESE COMPANIES THAT
PRODUCE FAKE DOCUMENTS FOR THESE
ILLEGALS ARE JUST SOARING.
WHAT’S GOING ON IN HOUSTON AND
BY THE WAY, A FEDERAL JUDGE IS
INSISTING THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION REIMPLEMENT
REMAIN IN MEXICO BUT MY SOURCES
ON THE GROUND SAID I’LL BELIEVE
IT WHEN I SEE IT.
THEY STILL THINK THEY’RE GOING
TO BLOW-OFF THE LAW.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON WHAT’S GOING ON
IN HOUSTON AS WELL AS THE RIEU
MAIN IN MEXICO POLICY.
>> THE REMAIN IN MEXICO, THAT
WAS A RESULT OF A LAWSUIT WHERE
A FEDERAL JUDGE RULED IN OUR
FAVOR COMPELLING THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO REINSTATE THE
REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY.
WE ARE APPREHENSIVE ABOUT THE
EXTENT TO WHICH THE BUY BEN BIDE
ADMINISTRATION WILL REIMPOSE IT.
THE NEWS REPORTS ARE THEY’RE
GOING TO BEGIN DOING IT.
I THINK THEY’VE GOTTEN AGREEMENT
BY THE MEXICAN GOVERNMENT TO
BEGIN THE PROCESS, BEGINNING
THIS WEEKEND, EARLY NEXT WEEK.
BUT OF COURSE AS USUAL, WE’LL
BELIEVE IT WHEN WE SEE IT.
WITH REGARD TO THESE CRIMES THAT
YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT TAKING
PLACE, LISTEN, THIS IS PART OF
CARTEL ACTIVITY.
THE CARTELS ARE ADVERTISING ON
TIKTOK TO GET DRIVERS TO ASSIST
AND THEN MOVING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AROUND THE STATE OF
TECHS AS.
IT’S AN ISSUE THAT THE TEXAS
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY IS
WORKING TO CRACK DOWN UPON.
IT SHOWS THE EXTENT TO WHICH
TEXAS LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS
HAVE TO STEP UP AND DEAL WITH
THE CHALLENGES THAT A ARE
CREATED BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IMPORTING ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY INTO OUR COUNTRY AND
INTO OUR STATE.
MARIA:  YEAH.
WELL, WE WILL LEAVE IT THERE.
GOVERNOR, THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP.
GOOD TO TALK WITH YOU THIS
MORNING.
WE HAVE REPORTED ON THE TIKTOK